blanche présent bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur le plateau
de rtl france pour commencer peut-être
un mot sur le protocole parce qu'il a
fait réagir un cette grande table qui
éloignait les deux hommes personne sur
le tarmac 1 pour accueillir emmanuel
macron qu'est ce que on peut en retenir
qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
d'abord le protocole sanitaire puisque
si j'ai bien compris la délégation
française a subi un test dans l'avion
quand il est atterri à corte lattes et à
un reflux covo y avait quand même eu un
petit comité d'accueil dont
l'ambassadeur de france c'est son devoir
d'être au pied de la paix celle de le
couper de l'avion et puis effectivement
cette grande table ovale dans une salle
solennelle puisqu'on est au kremlin et
que tout et cela d'elle au kremlin cette
grande table ovale d'habitude vladimir
poutine il reçoit ses hôtes sur le côté
le plus étroit de la table ovale mais à
cause du protocole sanitaire il reçoit
tous ses invités sur le diagonal la plus
la plus grande voilà pour que ça donne
cette impression de distance avec la
solitude puisque c'est une salle assez
grande et que on ne voit pas d'autres
personnages il y avait entendu dans des
cabines séparé des interprètes un pour
chaque côté et puis dans une autre salle
des preneur de notes puisque c'est de la
diplomatie et que on prend note de tout
ce qui est dit de façon à pouvoir
progresser par rapport aux propos qui
ont été tenus à la séance antérieur
alors justement sur le fond de cette
rencontre cette fois on a entendu des
différences entre les deux hommes et
puis aussi des convergences qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir de cet échange ce
matin alors je crois que ce marathon ça
durait quand même près de six heures a
été très structuré c'est à dire que les
deux chefs d'état ont évoqué différents
sujets à commencer par le dombass est le
plus urgent puisque ce matin le
président mâcon va rencontrer le
président ukrainien et s'ils ont le don
basso on a l'impression que quelque
chose bouge puisque les la russie a
accepté que les et sherpa les
conseillers diplomatiques les présidents
se réunissent il ya une dizaine de jours
à paris et qu' ils vont se réunir à
nouveau le 10 février à berlin donc
quelque chose est en train de bouger et
c'est très important en effet que
d'abord le cessez le feu soit totalement
respectée ensuite que les prisonniers
soient échangés il en reste encore pas
mal et puis que on débloque cette
situation sur la manière d'organiser des
élections dans le donbass est
effectivement monsieur poutine a insisté
sur la lettre de l'accord de minsk qui
prévoit que des conversations doivent
avoir lieu entre le gouvernement de kiev
et les autorités de fait de louanges et
le donetsk des deux enclaves qui sont
russophones et et qui font plus ou moins
cession actuellement donc c'est ceci qui
doit progresser dans les jours qui
viennent avec aussi l'aide aux essieux
puisque l'organisation sur la sécurité
et la coopération en europe est parti
aux accords de minsk bien entendu et
puis ensuite en deuxième lieu il y à la
sphère de l'otan est là dessus monsieur
poutine a été très clair puisque il a
fait comprendre que ça l'était l'intérêt
de personne que l'ukraine rentrer dans
l'otan puisque ils divergent sur
la souveraineté en crimée et que cette
divergence serait apportée à l'intérieur
de l'otan si l'ukraine entrée dans
l'otan et que par conséquent les pays de
l'otan se retrouverait immédiatement en
guerre avec la russie ce qui n'est
souhaitable pour personne ça revient à
dire que en effet un pays divisé n'entre
pas l'otan ce qui d'ailleurs est la
règle chypre n'est jamais rentré à
l'otan pour cette raison et je pense que
de toute façon la france et l'allemagne
avaient en 2008 dit qu' il n'y avait pas
de raison pour que ces deux pays
rentrent dans l'otan donc là dessus je
pense que des convergences entre
monsieur vaqueront et monsieur poutine
et qu'on peut trouver entente mais
évidemment la demande russe va plus loin
puisqu'elle est pas d'extension
nouvelles de l'otan à l'est donc je
viens en parler pour le cren c'est le
même raisonnement pour la géorgie mais
pourrait y avoir d'autres d'autres cas
de figure
y compris en asie centrale et monsieur
poutine va plus loin en disant
il faut également retiré les systèmes
d'armes offensif qui pour qu'ils
pourraient avoir été installés dans les
pays riverains de la frontière russe
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs dans l'otan ou
qu'ils n'y soient pas
que j'ai une garantie une garantie
écrite que il pourra pas y avoir à
l'avenir installation de tels systèmes
offensifs autant ou américains alors ça
ça relève plutôt d'une négociation entre
la russie et les etats-unis qui par
ailleurs ont engagé une autre
négociation sur les questions
balistiques nucléaires qui se poursuit
qui se poursuivra et dernier point
évidemment monsieur mac on a fait preuve
de sa compréhension pour le souci de
revoir architecture de sécurité en
europe et que la russie
légitimement demande des garanties de
sécurité alors monsieur mâcon a ajouté
que c'était aussi valable pour les pays
qui était de l'autre côté de la
frontière qu'il s'agisse de pays de
l'otan comme les trois pays baltes ou
qu'il s'agisse de pays comme la
biélorussie at il dit ou bien la
moldavie ou bien l'ukraine et la géorgie
par conséquent un vaste chantier une
négociation d'une très grande complexité
qui est engagé est temps que la
négociation est engagé en effet et bien
il n'y a pas de conflit armé et c'était
ça quand même l'objectif principal
c'était de créer un espace de
négociation un espace pour la diplomatie
et de d'engager une désescalade pour
éviter tout conflit militaire alors au
marathon diplomatique qui va se
poursuivre vladimir poutine emmanuel
macron doivent s'entretenir dans
quelques jours et ce après cette
rencontre aujourd'hui entre emmanuel
macron et volodymyr zelensky à à kiev
quels sont les enjeux de cette rencontre
aujourd'hui très important parce que
effectivement
il faut aussi que volodymyr
zana ski et montre sa capacité à bouger
et à entraîne l'application
complète des accords de minsk ce qui est
difficile pour lui parce que il a une
opinion publique il a un parlement la
rada qui probablement
n'acceptera pas de bon gré des
concessions des concessions visant à
discuter avec les sécessionnistes et à
définir avec eux les règles suivant
lesquelles pourraient se passer les
élections surtout que la frontière entre
ces deux provinces de lourdes celle de
ness et la russie est totalement poreuse
et qu'elle n'est pour le moment pas
contrôler et bien sûr par kiev 10 par
l'ouest et d'ailleurs donc là il ya
probablement en matière à négociation
peut-être un rôle accru de l'ouest chez
eux ça n'est pas contraire aux accords
de minsk et ça pourrait permettre
d'aboutir à une solution merci beaucoup
claude pour votre éclairage ce matin l
élite au diplo de claude blanchet maison
à revoir sur les réseaux sociaux merci
[Musique]